[Music]
a prosthetic leg for one of the many
amputees who come to this Orthopedic
Center and artificial limb Workshop in
central Kiev Alexander stetsenko who's
one of the country's leading prosthetic
Engineers heats the plastic to bend the
mold into shape
Anatoly lost his leg fighting Russian
forces in mariopol almost a year ago
his prosthetic leg has been giving him
pain in recent weeks
we can adjust it from both sides
Alexander tells him he should be fine
then
foreign
it's a lot of work there are many very
complex very high amputations multiple
amputations where two arms and a leg are
missing
Anatoly lives in an explore apartment
it's a long walk up the stairs when the
lifts are not working
he lives here with his girlfriend Elena
and her baby Misha paulina's former
husband was killed fighting on the front
line last year
she is seven months pregnant with
anatoly's child
we are thinking of starting a business
you can't survive long on a government
handout so I am thinking of what to do
because Elena is pregnant
as a war amputee Anatoly will eventually
receive a one-off compensation payment
of around 21 700 dollars
the government also paid for his
prosthetic leg
it's difficult for him to move around he
tries of course but he mainly sits with
the child I have to do most of the
housework most of the 200 or so people
who come to this rehabilitation center
for therapy each week lost their limbs
fighting there are no official
statistics on how many people have lost
Looms in the war so far this prosthetic
limb is manufactured in Germany but
assembled here in Ukraine it has a
computer chip
at the back the data from which is
analyzed and the movement of the joint
adjusted accordingly
the price is astronomical 45
000 for this prosthetic leg there is
nothing like it being manufactured in
this country there are not enough
prosthetic limbs being built in Ukraine
for the growing number of military and
civilian amputees
the rehabilitation center is partly
funded by an Australian charity and
there's only one other as modern as this
in all Ukraine
there is a need because the
counter-offensive is expected and
unfortunately there's going to be a lot
more guys getting injured back at the
apartment Anatoly says he wishes he
could return to fight on the front line
but now his battle is to raise a young
growing family and to learn to live
again Charles Trafford Al Jazeera Kiev
ongoing heat waves across India